en su lucha contra el terrorismo en el
sahel en enero de 2013 el entonces
presidente de francia françois hollande
lanzó una operación cuyo único objetivo
era detener el terrorismo en la región
en ese momento la operación serbal
desplegó las tropas francesas para
impedir que los extremistas islamistas
se apoderaran del norte de mali en pocos
meses las tropas fundamentalistas habían
sido derrotadas la operación serbal
evolucionó entonces hacia la operación
var hand y en 2014 se formó el g5 sahel
reagrupando a los cinco principales
actores de la región mauritania mali y
burkina faso níger y chad pero con menos
fuerzas francesas sobre el terreno y
enfrentándose a una gran resistencia el
que 5 tuvo problemas en noviembre de
2015 al qaeda del magreb islámico atacó
el hotel radisson blu de bamako tomando
100 rehenes y matando a 20 personas
antes de que las fuerzas especiales
malienses pusieran fin al asedio unos
meses más tarde en enero de 2016 hombres
armados asaltaron un restaurante y el
hotel splendid en uagadugú en respuesta
a la creciente inestabilidad en la
región el presidente manuel mccone y los
miembros del g5 lanzaron el fcg 5s una
fuerza fronteriza conjunta para atacar a
los terroristas en cualquier país del
sahel pero los ataques continuaron y la
estabilidad ha sido difícil de mantener
en 2020 y 2021 malí se vio sacudida por
dos golpes militares
las protestas que acusan al ejército
francés de atacar a civiles en
bombardeos aéreos han deteriorado mucho
la situación en los últimos meses
tensiones que culminaron con la
expulsión del embajador francés en enero
bamako también ordenó la retirada de las
fuerzas especiales danesas del país
noruega es el último socio europeo que
ha abandonado sus planes de enviar
tropas a mali atribuyendo la decisión a
la falta de garantías para la seguridad
de sus soldados